well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages in the next half hour or so
then we'll see what's
making the headlines with the
broadcaster and journalist rachel
johnson
and the financial times whitehall editor
sebastian payne great to see you both
hello to you
as if we take a look at the front pages
the metro then quoting the home
secretary
pretty patel describing the sad end to
sarah everard's life
she was just walking home the sun
reports that a metropolitan police
officer
guarding miss everard's memorial site in
clapham
is under investigation for sharing a
tasteless
joke about her case in a group text
the financial times leading with the
decision of several
european governments to suspend use of
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
in order to investigate whether it can
lead to blood clots
though the world health organization has
insisted there's no need
the telegraph's headlined chaos in eu
over
oxford jab concerns the paper says
british scientists are baffled
by the suspension the times says
regulators
in the uk and europe have rushed to
defend the continued use of the vaccine
indeed the guardian points out that the
european medicines regulator has stated
there's no cause for concern the daily
mail suggests the move was a slight by
the eu because the vaccine
was made in britain the daily express
brands the decision
shameful calling it groundless and the
star meanwhile has the latest fallout
from piers morgan's exit
from good morning britain so lots to
discuss richard johnson sebastian payne
are here
rachel should we start with the
astrazeneca news then
um what do you think of this abundance
of caution uh
by european union nations despite the
european medicine's
agency suggesting that actually that the
the risk of covid outweighs the risk of
of side effects from this vaccine
well i mean i think they're right it's i
mean obviously we
you mentioned the daily mails front page
and they're making it into a political
fight
between uh the uk and the eu
it's clear that the 40 million people
have had the
extra zeneca vaccine 11 million people
in this country
they've been 35 to 40 cases of
blood clots apparently
if you're not vaccinated the chances of
blood cots are higher than if you are
so it seems to me unconscionable that
europe as italy goes into another
lockdown
and trying to cope with its third wave
of this
virus and pandemic that the europeans
are risking them all going back into
lockdown and
as seven i knew were saying earlier
risking like european holidays
yes highly irritating absolutely and and
that
i mean more broadly if if everyone's
vaccinated we're all safe if they're not
we're not is kind of the basis of that
isn't it
and the financial times then
astrazeneca's jab rollout paused in
europe over
blood clot fears the german health
minister specifically saying it's um the
very rare cerebral
um blood thrombosis effectively trying
to be very specific about this
um but it is as scientists have pointed
out sebastian
not uncommon to have clots isn't it
that's part of the problem with this is
extrapolating
the causal links really i know and it's
very odd there's something else that
causes blood clots a lot more of them a
lot more serious and that is covered 19
itself and that feels as if
it's got lost in this whole debate that
it's really unfathomable the fact that
germany
france italy and spain have all paused
roll out
of the astrazeneca vaccine on data that
is very dubious nobody can really
explain why
and both the european medical agency has
come out today and said there's no
reason to stop giving the jabs and
obviously the uk's mhra which would
prove the jobs they've also said
there's no evidence this too it's rather
a sorry tale for astrazeneca because
this came into the whole process
as the vaccine that was going to save
the world the
cheap affordable cover jab that was very
efficient
could be distributed easily and we've
seen that in the uk 11 million jabs
delivered already of just that single um
that single producer
but the company's been blighted by a lot
of issues it's had
the fact that it had supply problems
there was questions over the data
originally
but where should have been in a place
now where it is a good vaccine it is
clearly working when you look at the
death rates and hospitalization rates in
the uk the azer jab is a good
thing and this fear-mongering me really
worries me we've seen this before from
emmanuel macron
and it can obviously have very deadly
consequences as rachel was saying
yes and indeed go on rachel i was just
going to ask
whether sebastian knows as he knows
everything whether the countries that
are pausing the rollout of the az
vaccine are offering their pop civilian
populations
an alternate vaccine the problem is that
all the supply for vaccines has been
done through the ema
centrally and the ema doesn't have a
problem with the astrazeneca vaccine
they've come out today and said
as far as we're concerned you can keep
on jabbing it's up to
individual countries to make that
decision and so they're not going to
replace those supplies
and like the uk and many other parts of
the world the whole of europe's vaccine
strategy
is based on astrazeneca so if they keep
pausing it
and if european leaders keep raising
doubts about the vaccine that really
doesn't bode well for keep for
tackling the pandemic on the continent
and interestingly actually rachel's um
sort of uh next to your question not
quite similarly mexico has asked america
for their
doses of astrazeneca which they've not
yet given permission for they obviously
wanted more studies done on the
over 65 so while it's not being used
mexico said give it to us so people
still want it
but it is really important isn't it this
this vaccine because it's cheaper
and it only requires refrigeration not
freezing and all of that
for the roll out to the rest of the
world which is why reputational damage
to this vaccine
which has already been clobbered by the
questions about its efficacy in over 65s
that could be really serious couldn't it
globally
it could be i mean i think we're
awaiting a kind of pan-european decision
from the what is it ema isn't it
and if they if they can pass it good to
go
i i cannot see the obstacle in the
countries
they're up to a dozen european countries
now including really big ones you know
like france italy germany and spain
have paused the rollout tonight i think
i think it's
you know it'll be actually an
international incident if they did
because as you said in your opening
remarks
it's not until we're all vaccinated that
we're all safe
the daily telegraph then british
scientists are baffled
as more nations cease use of the
astrazeneca vaccine
chaos in europe over the oxford jab
concerns and
rachel's already mentioned the daily
mail reckless eu snubs uk
jab um is it politics do you think or is
this an abundance of caution
uh by our european neighbors sebastian
what what's your bet on that
oh i don't think it's really politics i
don't think
no matter how anybody knew feels about
brexit in the uk i don't think they
would stop giving covey jabs
just for politics which is the what's
being inferred on the daily mail in the
daily express tomorrow i think
fundamentally
this is all about an abundance of
caution and the strategy the uk has
taken is to act
quite nimbly especially for the state
that our government
and to attack things by trying out new
vaccines
doing the approval process in the
expedited rate and generally it has paid
off
for example increasing the the length
between doses that's something other
countries have followed the uk's lead on
that when it was found
that is actually the best way to get an
effective vaccine there
um i have sympathy with this because no
government wants to be responsible
for vaccinating its population and
creating extra problems
but the data is so low here and as
rachel said at the beginning
actually once you've had the vaccine and
the the amount of blood clots
actually um decreases so it does seem as
if there's a bit of a panic reaction and
i think
this is all due to those earlier
concerns with astrazeneca
those concerns about over the 60 farms
which were unfounded by the way because
there was enough data
when germany made that decision that
sent everybody in panic
earlier in the earlier in the year and
then the supply issues as well
that's simply being a contractual
dispute between the eu and astrazeneca
but hopefully
we'll have a pause people will calm down
we'll look at the data and realize that
yes
it is fine and the who oxford university
the uk
the mhra they are all right on this and
it can start again quite soon because
europe's curve situation is a pretty bad
place as we saw in one of the papers
tomorrow
italy's heading back into lockdown again
yes germany and france also seeing
rising figures and hopefully too rachel
people here in the uk
will continue to have confidence in this
vaccine because the uptake here
has been largely extraordinary
yes i mean and also when you turn up at
a center i don't think that you can
elect to choose one vaccine over another
i mean i think it would be
stupid if anybody to turn up and say no
i don't want the oxford vaccine i want
the pfizer vaccine if the pfizer vaccine
is there then or well and good ditto the
oxford one
i just can't understand it the
statistics don't seem to
bear out so many of these european
countries
abundance of caution as well it's
actually it's not a cautious it's
actually
reckless not to continue the roll out of
the
vaccinations given what what's happening
to the infection rates i
i can't understand it at all but i don't
i think i agree with deb it is not
politics
but i don't know what it is yeah okay
and the interesting thing is that the
the worries about the over 65s and that
efficacy
even raised by the french president
sebastian have been
truly answered have they not here with
the vaccine gap that we now see
between cases depending what age you're
in so that i mean that hopefully has put
that concern
to bear doesn't it at least that one
absolutely and when these reports came
out from germany about the fact it
wasn't going to get approved
over 65 it wasn't because there wasn't
data or data to the country it's because
they didn't have enough of it they were
saying we're not going to approve this
because we're not certain enough but
really what you're seeing in the uk is a
mass trial you know i said 11 million
people plus 7 million of these jabs
have been delivered across the eu
already and when you look
there is a very clear mark now on those
charts between the effects of lockdown
and social distancing but clearly
the effects of the vaccine the key thing
that astrazeneca jab has done
is to break that link between infections
and serious illness because that's what
caused all the problems
over the past year that people get
coveted a certain proportion get them
get very ill and in a certain portion of
those end up in hospital
that's the key thing that governments
have been trying to address whether it's
pfizer
astrazeneca or moderna all those
vaccines do seem to have done that
i should say on the azad jab though the
key indication of this of course will be
america
the director of the national health
institute which is the us's equivalent
of the mhra
their currently reviewing the data and
the us could approve astrazeneca within
a month
and if that does happen then that could
certainly put the whole world in a much
better place and try and rebuild some of
that muslim confidence
in this jab absolutely and the european
uh medicines regulator we understand
meeting tomorrow
decision hopefully by thursday so we'll
see if this is indeed
a temporary pause um both of you thank
you so much for now plenty more still to
come including
as the fallout from the sarah everard
case continues we will
discuss the parallel issues of women's
safety
and the right to protest join us well
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now rachel johnson and
sebastian payne
welcome back here there you are welcome
back to both of you
um plenty of coverage uh also about the
sarah everard murder the vigil that we
saw at the weekend
the statement from pretty patel in the
house of commons today
and the policing bill it's all kind of
wrapped together now isn't it sebastian
the metro taking it very straight really
pretty patel's heartache
over sarah she was just walking home the
five words that sum up the emotions that
have
triggered this outpouring
yes and the home secretary gave a
statement um in the house of commons and
it was a very powerful
very emotional statement from pretty
battal actually where she was talking
about how unacceptable
um the actions were and also looking at
the met policing of that vigil on
saturday night which created which
created
so much of a backlash there and when you
look at this case which is still
gut wrenching for not just people me and
people of my generation who feed us if
everyone knows someone who would have
been in sarah everard's
circumstances and but i think the whole
of london has really
felt in a bad way about this um and
it does feel as if we are at a big
moment in terms of our national
conversation
about violence against women about
making our streets safer and
the pm had a meeting of this new task
force today where they've agreed to
double the funding
for safer streets they're going to
increase the number of plain clothes
police officers
who are patrolling areas near pubs and
bars and restaurants to try and improve
all those sorts of things but the thing
that's missing from this whole formula
is the criminal justice system that when
you look at the
tiny proportion of actual prosecutions
and convictions that go down
on violence against women that's what
really needs to be addressed i know it's
not a simple or
a headline grabbing thing but that is
really going to be the most important
thing and i think
they are serious about trying to get
something good from this horrific
episode
that's where the focus needs to be and
just quickly rachel uh labor is trying
to unpick specifically the home
secretary's role in all of this
which has been picked up by the guardian
too uh suggesting that pretty patel
spoke to the
met police commissioner before the vigil
was broken up which is
becomes interesting again doesn't it
well yeah it does raise the question as
to what was the plan for this vigil
and was the the manhandling of female
protesters
um arranged in advance i mean did they
have any sense of what they were going
to do i've spoken to people because i
hosted a radio show for two hours
one of them was at the vigil she said
the police just surrounded the bandstand
there was no apparent order there was no
apparent strategy
had they just um allowed the women there
were no lose it was very cold the women
would could have just dispersed
naturally they kind of created
their own disaster um by not having a
plan and now we
it's established that pretty patel and
crestedic did
confer before i have to say though um
i speaking as a woman would find it
ironic
if either pretty patel or the or the met
commissioner
had to go over this issue um ironic that
a really top woman's head would roll
over an issue of male violence against
women i think they are trying to do
their best think christopher dick has
the confidence
of the home secretary and the prime
minister that was made very clear
um i know that everybody's going to hide
under the cover and kick
if this into the long grass around the
investigations that have been announced
um there were two investigations
announced yesterday
rachael there is money on the table as
well okay
we will talk more about that at half
eleven there's plenty to discuss isn't
there rachel sebastian
thank you both thank you